in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Ben and
Allison are with us hey guys how are you
hi Dave hey welcome welcome where y'all
from Tuscaloosa Alabama
all right home of the tide it's a
beautiful town we went down to a game
and watch you guys shellac you see a
couple of years ago and really enjoyed
the the visit other than the football
but yeah it was very good Congrats
welcome to welcome to Nashville so
you're here to do your debt-free scream
we are very cool and how much have you
paid off 80,000 80,000 bucks way to go
making how long did that take you 36
months and making what kind of money we
started it around 90 and now we're at
150 excellent what do you guys do for a
living I am I work for the university
I'm a director I deal with financial
information systems ah there we go
good and I'm a Quality Assurance
engineer in the automotive industry good
for you okay very cool you're both doing
really well congratulations excellent
career is very well done so I'm gonna
guess and say the 80000 had some student
loans in it it did yeah how much of it
was student loans okay and and what else
was the dad cars card credit cards and
car so you were normal you know stable
knowledge card debt credit card debt and
how long have you guys been married four
years okay so it's a year after you're
married something happens and you decide
we're gonna get crazy and get out of
debt what happened well for us our
pastor in July but the month before we
started our budget and doing everything
the right way he gave a sermon on being
good stewards over money in the biblical
way and that really walked our world but
you know alison has actually a different
reason for that we actually finally
opened up our Total Money Makeover
packet Bennett bought it for us as an
engagement gift and we just never opened
it and we were headed to visit some
friends and Clemson and we were
listening to the audio book and you were
telling a story about this family who
couldn't afford all these Christmas
gifts they were buying for their fan
it just got really depressing and I told
Ben I was like if this doesn't get
better I'm just gonna open the door and
jump out did you get better you did talk
about how to get yourself out of it how
to stay out of it and so we just decided
then on that that was something that we
wanted to do you know we don't want be
those people now and and we do want to
be good stewards and so the combination
of the two just decided to get on track
and the Total Money Makeover he gave you
the plan then well actually our church
vineyard John quits the pasture he
actually let us do that of course that
for after year the church also that was
good and we've done that three times now
okay so you're the coordinators yeah
actually on the way of doing a momentum
at our church next year we're preparing
for that oh my goodness Wow yeah very
cool well thank you that's that's an
impressive very neat so why do you tell
people when you're leading a Financial
Peace University class because now
you're a success story I mean you're the
testimony you got the $80,000 paid off
in 36 months what do you tell them the
secret to getting out of that is I think
for me especially from a male
perspective it's you you need to be a
good leader for your household for your
family you got to take care of you first
before you take care of anybody else but
especially for people who are owning
loans on your debt on you that's that
you don't want to take care of the
bankers family or the car lot guys
family want to take care of yours so
that's that's key for me I think yeah
getting that change of perspective of
who's winning in this equation yeah very
cool what about you Allison
I think patience was the biggest thing
for me patience and contentment not
being a spoiled adult yeah that was so
good
took a lot of adjusting too so just
setting a plan and doing it over a long
course of time you know not running out
and getting my mom mobile or bigger this
or bigger that so yeah the patience of
it all yeah thirty thousand bucks a year
almost 25 between 25 and 30 a year for
three years that's very good pace that
you knocked this off very very well done
I mean you had a lot to clean up
and you did it you did it with you know
I'm guessing with your incomes going up
that it probably a lot of it happened in
the last year right all right we
you've got to keep our step lifestyle
the same as our income went up so it
didn't make it a lot yeah but that
that's the patience and contentment are
kind of tied together are the house yes
yeah that's that's very true and you
know and everybody around just going
crazy so it's hot I mean did people make
fun of y'all well Ben Ben writes about
financial literacy so people have called
him everything under the Sun so that's
that's always interesting it's it's also
reaffirming just to have to explain your
stance about things all the time so you
know I definitely I'm very proud of him
with that and being able to argue the
right way to do things even though
people come up with all sorts of reasons
yeah people arguing tooth and nail about
how carve a new car is like a great idea
and I can't no idea like I don't know if
I could help you or not that that's true
so did you guys grow up rich poor middle
class or what I think for us like this
two difference perspective I had a
pretty meager you know lifestyle you
know we were good Christian family but
now out of money good good moral get
Christian background but not a lot of
money yeah we were we were middle-class
I didn't hear no much that's what you
said spoiled adult and I kind of keyed
off on that so you kind of brought that
in with you and I don't think you were
either I don't think you were either but
it's you know like you said you just you
didn't hear no a lot there wasn't a lot
of lack and so to have to dial back and
intentionally as an act of your
intellect as an act of your will create
like to get more like you know to get in
control that that touches that same
place doesn't it it does and then I mean
that's been a big growing you know
factor for me especially during marriage
and having to do it together and not
wanting to be the baby in the room or
you know the not wanting to be the
person who was wanting this and I want
that and I want this and so you know Ben
had a lot more discipline and just a lot
more perspective on things than I did
mmm-hmm okay that's very cool very
well-spoken excellent you guys are a
sharp rock star Club
man I'm proud of you excellent this is
fun alright Ben and Alison Tuscaloosa
Alabama 80,000 bucks paid off in 36
months making 90 now make it a hundred
and a half count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one
very very very well done